I'm going to tell you all right now
nobody's got the wisdom of an old black
man so one Friday night I come in and
John Lewis goes Brian
what are you doing when you get off
tonight and like I said it could be
three or four in the morning and I was
like
I don't know I'm probably just going to
smoke a joint and go to bed what about
you John Lewis and he leans in and he
goes I'm gonna [__] my wife
I was like oh my God
it's like that John Lewis
I'm like what are you a newlywed or some
[__] and he goes no I've been with the
same woman for over 30 years I go holy
[__]
at your age you're still [__] like
that at four in the morning
you got to teach a young man the secret
right now
and he leans in he goes Ryan
you gotta make that [__] pop
and the way he yelled pop
and the way I jumped
I knew I had never made a [__] pop
guys tomorrow my special Lefty sun drops
on my YouTube channel it's going up at
midnight you can get it right this the
second it turns April 5th all right
catch me on those podcasts out there
promoting the special like it comment on
it share it subscribe thank you for your
support the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we
are over here doing it in the night
pants Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media and as every week I want to
say thank you thank you for supporting
this show thank you for following us hit
subscribe on that goddamn thing hit
subscribe it's a free way to help the
show as you know we tackle tough
subjects over here and we get
demonetized non-stop because of the
content we talk about so what happens is
YouTube may we make no money off YouTube
and then they don't throw your episodes
out into the algorithm but if you
subscribe it's always there for you you
see what I'm saying also if you gotta
have more then you got to check out the
patreon it's called the Honeydew with
y'all and I highlight the low lights
with you all and I'm telling you every
week I say this and I think what the
[__] are we gonna hear this week that's
going to be every week we just talked to
a kid who was I said this already in a
in the classroom of the Michigan State
shooter where two of the students died
uh we talked to a guy who just had a
double lung transplant and how he got
the lungs it made history it's we've
talked to people who've solved cold
cases who've died we've talked to
everybody you guys have the wildest
stories it's five dollars a month that's
it you sign up for a year you get over a
month free you get the Honeydew a day
early you get it ad free you get it at
no additional cost and you get audio and
video so you don't have to just watch
all right and if you're looking for a
new podcast check out my old one the
crab Feast it's an audio podcast all the
people you love from podcasting are
right there on it all right uh dates
we're slowly getting back into it after
everything that [__] happened so
we're gonna start in May May 26th and
27th I'll be in Fort Wayne Indiana June
23rd and 24th Tacoma Washington July 7th
and 8th Appleton Wisconsin and July 21st
and 22nd I'm in Tulsa Oklahoma all right
we're going to start there and we're
going to add dates as we go make sure
you're checking out my special on
YouTube Lefty son right there also free
all this content's free hit subscribe
you get it for free all right now you
guys know what we do over here we
highlight the low lights and I always
say these are the stories behind the
storytellers very excited to have this
guest on today first timer on the
Honeydew ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Rick Glassman welcome to the
Honeydew Rick
thank you young man absolutely I'm
realizing I don't have headphones and
I'm not sure how how we picking up over
here you want to sit up on that mic I
want to or you do both I mean you want
to be back here I mean listen these are
the best mics in the world right if
you're right if you're right if you're
right on this right right yeah
absolutely uh look before we get too far
into it plug and uh promote everything
Rick lastman at the top I'd like to plug
the rode psa1 mic arm which if you have
it right here you could be bringing it
wherever you're sitting and you're
staying in France
they make too much and I'd also like to
promote wearing sunglasses so people
could see you're not always a dork
[Music]
these are intimate conversations we like
to lean into the trauma yeah I love a
leaning I love to have an option of a
leaning so I could do something like by
the way did I tell you
but if I'm here the whole time it's like
appreciating the sunny days because of
the rain it's all rain
yeah we highlight the rain here bro yeah
well
it's good to be back are you comfortable
yeah it's good to be back
I I open with it's good to be back
all the time um including places I've
never been to well promote everything
now please
you have a great podcast
take your shoes off thank you so much
um that sometimes you do in your parents
store is that it's not always
um I have a I have a within the taking
shoes off um universe
we have the sleepover series the
sleepover series is where I take four
suitcases and I go places with it
um and when I go uh back home to
Cleveland I do it in my dad's rug store
well
my family's not in carpet I I started my
own carpet business I wasn't in
Marshalls we'll be right back with the
word from our sponsors
if you're looking for just the right
flooring you need choices but don't you
if you're looking for a Marshall Carpet
um voice over don't you need choices
anyway at Marshall Carpet what is it
Marshall Carpet One or is at Marshall
Carpet One you'll find thousands of
choices
[Music]
oh it's March well you have to look at
this to know it's called Carpet One I
thought that's what it was but you keep
saying it wrong so I thought maybe it's
written wrong well I could I don't know
Marshall Carpet so I could have been and
at Marshall Carpet One you'll find
thousands of choices
okay uh mark that I want to come back in
that moment but I still do need the
voiceover so I'm I know I know I'm it's
like working with scores and easy anyway
I and at Marshall Carpet One you'll find
thousands of choices you get you're
giggling over my voice over there
they're isolated tracks
they're isolated I'm telling you they're
going to hear the laughter start from
the top
if you're looking for just the right
flooring you're yelling
if you're looking do you how how should
I present this the way you're asked you
should feel this right yeah oh real
before you do this I want to let you
know that if you're looking for just the
right flooring you need choices and at
Marshall Carpet One and rug Gallery we
got thousands of choices from hardwood
linoleum vinyl rugs these types of
things so listen make the right choice
and visit Marshall Carpet One in rug
Gallery today
and
and we promise with more with more than
50 50 years of family-owned business
we've got you covered and you could if
you want you could say we've got you
covered or you could go away like we've
got you covered covered
whenever you don't have an echo machine
okay I'll do it all right
if you're looking for just the right
flooring you need choices and at
Marshall's Carpet One Marshall
I'm taking the s from the sh H sound of
course and I'm putting it at the end I
was doing Marvels must be the OCD
you're trying to control of all the s's
you're right
and at Marshall Carpet One you'll find
thousands of choices including carpet
hardwood rugs and luxury vinyl so make
the right choice and visit Marshall
Carpet One and rug gallery and we
promise with more than 50 years as a
family-owned business
we've got you covered covered covered
covered covered
covered
and we're back and uh we're back
um martial art gallery shout out to the
Martian plug-in please that's a family
it's family business you kidding me we
talk about all that you just gave Road a
plug [__] and their mic arm let's yeah
I could be sitting back and relaxing
right now I'm about to get a new rug
what are you talking about we'll take
care of you but you'll have to sit on
the rug in a certain way
um yeah you know Rick Glassman on
Instagram and uh you know
that's it all right shows well you know
I don't know when this comes out and
what shows I'll have but you know just
look on look at my insta there we go are
you on are you doing tour dates at all
you know I'm gonna tell you something
Ryan Ryan
I don't have a stand-up agent
and um I was never really a draw to go
on the road and
my podcast kind of started doing pretty
well over the pandemic but I stopped
doing stand-up for a while I started up
again last January uh and since then
it's been like people coming out it
feels really cool I want to go on the
road
um so I'm like in the Press it's like I
think I need to get a stand-up agent but
I haven't done it I'm just doing you
know 20 minutes in town 15 to 20 in town
that's what these shows are for and
that's what I think it's this yeah right
here but specifically right here oh
sorry this um yeah
the the fact that
you can create a show like you have and
then it gets successful and then you
have this other tool in your bag of
stand up because a lot of people they're
podcasting you know I I equate
podcasting fans like in a good way to
like D and D fans you know they're very
into they don't give a [__] if you're a
huge athlete or a huge celebrity as long
as you're one of the two but if you're
if you're not in the podcasting World
they don't give a [__] they don't give a
[__] and I love that about them but the
other thing is some of them aren't
necessarily stand-up fans they're
podcast fans they like the long format
whatever not the standing up one person
they like the interaction but
you have this tool in your bag that now
you can get back out and do stand up
with so then you're giving people
content free content every week and then
they can come out and appreciate you
although that's the other thing my I'm
very fortunate I have great [__] fans
and they say all the time like you've
given us 12 years of free podcast like
the least we could do it started 12
years ago crab Feast was we that was
seven and a half years you get some
before that no and now this has been
four years what's 12 then well seven and
a half and four and a half but seven and
a half years ago well that's when no no
that's how long the podcast lasted that
was the Run yeah this is why we need the
mic on seven and a half yeah I
couldn't hear you
a Little Closer
um how are these switches are we getting
these fun switches and we're good
because there's a lot of a lot of
cadence between our movements right now
and this is our wide right here in case
we need we might be living a little bit
uh anyway get out there get an agent go
do something you don't understand people
anymore that's what I'm saying now they
need you need them to get you the gigs
but before it was like just put me out
there you're right you're not drawing
they're giving tickets away whatever
yeah but now you're selling tickets so
go out there build that you've got that
in your bag you're a great stand-up
comedian I'm really happy with with
where my stand-up is right now really
really happy
um a bit
I don't know if nervous is the right
word but like I think that's a good
starting off point um
uncomfortable Maybe
nervous about like um when people come
out to see me
and have listened to this and listened
to me and heard the things I have to say
which is a good thing because they're
already on board with me sure if I get
pretty insecure about
saying stuff that they've already heard
even topics I said this to you like what
we're about to talk about I've talked
about a little bit before on like the
are you garbage podcast and like I'll
talk about it again great podcast love
those guys I did it a long long time ago
I want them both on this podcast and I
want to go they are garbage I I've met
him twice them on mine and mine on
theirs
one of the best Duos I've ever seen yeah
they're great they're very different
they're so funny like I watch them like
like I'm so into them and they're so
nice I think I mean they're doing great
so sure but I just like like I've
introduced them to my friends who may
not who don't listen to podcasts that
much necessarily like listen to these
guys they're so great
um but the point I was saying is like uh
uh I did a rick Glassman and friends
show and it was awesome and and like uh
a ton of people came out and they all
knew me and and I had this interesting
feeling I never had before which is like
what you work for you work to get this
for people to come see me not just come
to see comedy and I'm there
where I felt like uh I'm sorry if I'm
not
gonna do great you know like I never
cared
um
I cared I never let that kind of um
control what I spoke on uh and now
there's this thing where it's like you
guys may have already heard me talk
about this or something and that makes
me feel a little uncomfortable does that
connect with you at all yeah it
absolutely does but also like talking to
Bert Chrysler because I said the same
thing like I told this one story on my
album but I don't have it anywhere on
video ever it doesn't I don't own it I
don't have anything should I put it in
my special and he's like Ryan
people who've listened to your album
aren't going to see your special they
don't this person doesn't watch Comedy
Central this whatever so so his whole
point was I've told the machine Story
how many goddamn times and I've put it
everywhere and then boom turns into a
goddamn summer blockbuster so yeah so I
hear you on so in my special Lefty son
you can watch it on YouTube
um I told a story that I've told on my
last album only because it was audio
only nothing else that I repeat but I
love that story so much and I felt like
it worked so well so I I wasn't
apologetic about including it because I
know there's still so many people that
haven't even [__] seen it right also
it's better now than it was yes yes
um
here's the thing I want to say about you
like I don't know you very well but I
know you have been a fan I was a fan of
yours when you were on on uh Undateable
I believe it was was it not the show you
were on with everyone could I call you
out yeah
I'm not gonna yeah but for two things
one yeah it was on data
what I'm not going to call you out I
want to but I've called me out well it's
it's it's that thing that happened not
you when people like I'm a fan of you
from this thing and like you know no one
was a fan of me from that thing I wasn't
a fan of you from that thing if I said
that I I'm a fan of yours I know you did
this show but I love that yeah I I
wasn't I wasn't introduced to Rick
lastman on Undateable
um I saw you in comedy before that
gotcha and you're a different guy which
is what stood out to me yeah was it a
very eclectic group of comedians from
the Bro mmas to Wallflowers where on the
show or just in our business I'm talking
about and you stand out to me as a
different guy among different people
isn't it such a you've got a Herald
famous vibe to me you know I've played
Harold Ramis I I do know that yeah which
is what when I saw that you were cast
for that I was like that is [__]
perfect Allison Jones is he gone before
you yeah he was Alison Jones is a
casting director who is the casting
director as far as I'm concerned for
comedy she did Golden Girls Fresh Prince
oh my God Curb Your Enthusiasm 40 year
old virgin super bad like she does
she's amazing uh and I fortunately have
she has worked with me before and cast
me things that I had a little bit of
relate have a little relationship with
her and and I sent her a picture of a
side by side of me and Harold and I said
don't audition anybody else and I don't
know if she did or she didn't but
she like walked me through it and like
had me come in a couple times let's fix
the voice I got a voice coach she like
manufactured a way to make it happen I
think
um and I got to work with David Wayne
who
um I had my bulletin board directors I
want to work with when I moved here it
was um Edgar Wright and David Wayne two
people I always want to work with and it
was him
um
that was such a [__] cool experience
I also knew nothing of that story do you
know about that stuff it's the origins
of the National Lampoon where Saturday
Night Live came from and Caddyshack and
the the Inception of like R-rated comedy
for the first time and it was just like
it was just an awesome movie I I mean it
came out in 2017 there's no reason to
really plug it but I don't talk about it
much it's called a futile and stupid
gesture and comedy fans I think really
really would like it
yeah you're different you're a different
dude and I watch a podcast and you watch
podcasts yeah I watch your clips and I
watch a little bit of your podcasts for
sure I started watching podcasts
recently I stopped because you're so
into it I started listening to music
again because I was missing you I was
missing music you know I'm listening all
this talk and I'm like
shut the [__] up you listening to comedy
podcasts when you were yeah yeah welcome
back to another episode of honeydew my
name is Rick Glassman with our host Ryan
sickler and if you know us you know that
we are often demonetized the reason is
because we keep in the stuff and if you
want to support the show you can check
out our patreon you could sign up for 12
months you get a month free you get to
see the episodes one day early and you
get them ad free also I will be in Tulsa
Oklahoma or you will be July 21 22. I'm
not sure but that's true that's pretty
impressive dude let's get into the show
right now I want to talk to you about
how I'm kind of a different brief you
are dude you know I've been a fan of
mine this is updateable uh could I
actually call me out that's not true I
know you were on Undateable yeah
um I know you've asked but I break baby
I know you do well I know you do a lot
of different things you do stand up here
and actors we just talked about the
Harold Ramis I'm a drama actor now too
but are you really oh yeah you're on uh
what's that why don't you say what show
that is
is it still up there on Amazon it's
called as we see it
but uh yeah uh you know drama I like
drama just keep doing what the [__]
you're doing please okay you're doing it
right go out and see these fans that
watch your podcast they want to meet you
they want to get to know you it's so
cool meeting people who like it's come
up to me and uh they don't try to shake
my hand they already know they give me
this and like there's been a few people
I talked about it I think once maybe not
twice with this I don't love an arm
around picture
not I don't love the touching aspect
because I don't know you but that's not
the I don't I don't I mean touch me it's
that's that's not that big of a deal I
just one of my I don't that's not
natural that's not a thing I just don't
like it and people come up to me and
they want to take pictures and they go
like I I'll just and I said it once I'll
get behind you and it's just like
there's a shorthand like they've already
accepted me which is uh
yeah I don't know man Bobby Lee talked
about this uh years ago when I had a
moment about the first time before I had
a little bit of an audience and it's
like yeah and you said it too the
podcast audience is a very specific
thing so it yeah it's just very little
die hards and so loyal
um
you know the the meet and greets I get
to do like
people cry you know they come up to but
here's the right way because the shows
meant so much to them this this show is
a different show where people
reconnected with family or started
therapy or whatever like we got some
we're a generation of messy Bros like
our dad's Generations were the guys that
were like walk it off how old are you
I'm 51. I'm 22.
yeah you look great dude
all right
uh thank you you look great dude for 22.
yeah
what are you laughing at because there's
no way in hell you're 20 [__]
two okay pull that driver's license out
right now I don't want it to be on here
I'll show you good point good point show
me after speaking of a good point yeah I
gotta say you have done a wonderful job
did we get that on the switch are we in
frame
the thing about podcasting that I love
is that again these people don't know
Rick glassman's character from
Undateable and that's why they're coming
to see you they know you I just realized
that this point stuff I'm doing no
context it was pre you yeah
before we got started Ryan was doing a
little pale but they know you like you
said they know the bump they know the
fist bump already they know that you're
not about this they already know that
they don't know that from Joe Blow on
this sitcom you know so it's a it's it's
a more interesting Connection in your
audience what do you think about a
sitcom
called sitcom and the characters names
of Joe Blow yada yada you know and just
doing all the all the sitcom divide you
know what I'm not gonna talk about it
I'm gonna pitch it yeah you should
really pitch that yeah
um but again getting to you being a
different person in this in this art
especially
um are you an only child so tell me how
you grew up because you there's a story
we're going to talk about and I'm
curious because it happens early on
eight nine you said no no it was eight
ninth grade eight ninth grade oh okay uh
also as I told you before I just want to
acknowledge or I think I already said it
if you heard this before you know I'm
sure he'll have some new stuff give me a
break there's only so many words you
know what I mean we do this every
[__] week calm down okay eight ninth
grade uh yeah I grew up uh with one
older brother two and a half years still
actually older than me
and uh how old he
he's uh almost I think he's about to be
25 okay
well done well done bro
[Laughter]
I know I can put you in the box and not
trip you up well done dude um he lives
out here
[Music]
I don't know what we're laughing at but
I'm having fun
it's so good dude I'm your facial hair
okay it ages me up a little your brother
is older where you guys from Ohio yeah
Cleveland
um our arms are tired and he's out here
he's got a he's a restaurateur he's got
a couple of restaurants out in uh in
Highland Park called the Greyhound okay
and um
yeah he lives here too a lot of a lot I
have a lot of family that lives in Los
Angeles now
they came out here
my mom's from New York but she moved out
to California when she was 11. so my mom
a lot of my mom's family is still out
here
um my dad's sister's out here so it
means my cousins my brother and I and my
Cleveland cousin shout out to Uncle Bob
his son Danny the replenish baby uh he
lives out here so like I mean I have so
much family there's a lot of family out
here and that's nice is that nice I mean
you close to everybody and yeah yeah
when I first moved out here I got to
stay with my aunt
um for a few months like to get my my
[__] together uh while I was doing
background work and like
um having another aunt and uncle who
lived right by The Comedy Store so when
I was doing the Sunday money potlucks uh
Park up on King's drive so I you know
they had a parking pass so like it was
still like a 15 minute walk down the
mountain but you don't have to pay for
parking
um and like people who come out to those
bringer shows when you first started it
was it was fantastic having people here
so what happens in eighth ninth grade
for you where you have a shift what is
it what happened sure yeah uh also the
theme of this show is like talking about
the high highs or excuse me the low lows
I don't want to Define this as the
lowest of lows necessarily it's just
something that uh I'm comfortable I mean
whatever that's irrelevant but like this
is just something that uh there's some
meat in it and worth talking about but
like when you're talking about people
who all the [__] you talked about the
beginning and what the stuff they went
through and I'm like I had to go to a
special school listen you can't compare
trauma right trauma's trauma doesn't it
I tell people the people are worried
about writing into that show because
like I can't compete with that I'm like
we're not here to compete yeah your
story is your story
um
my brother is a brilliant guy uh
literally as of last year Jeopardy
champion now well he went on Jeopardy
and one yeah no [__] did he really so
what's a champion how many you gotta win
so he won he only won one this is the
second one he was it almost it's felt
like like in white man can't jump when
she's going through quiche and all the
things like he was he was literally
almost double the person the middle
person I'm really impressed that you
know that movie for only being 22.
that's in front okay
[Music]
and then just the the Final Jeopardy
question uh he missed
um and uh the person he was literally
almost double ahead so he couldn't have
to bet anything we were so bummed I say
we I mean he what I mean it's been his
dream forever I just you watched
jeopardy with him and so it's like why
are you not on it he knows everything
um and we're bummed that he because if
he he could have gone for so long he
missed one question anyway I say this
because my brother growing up was always
the smart one
and uh also maybe a little difficult and
um
high school for for us started in eighth
grade eighth through 12th was a school
okay so it's still not high school but
it's in that same big building so you
have these little kids who are in eighth
grade coming in not in high school but
still sharing the hallways with all the
older kids and I remember
my introduction into I always was in
like you know some like kind of like
learning disabled classes and and and uh
uh there's some other things they will
get into just like a little special like
oh why don't you try going to work with
these kids for a little type of stuff
and why were you did you struggle with
math or are you just not interested 80d
or I was diagnosed with that I don't
know if that is what it is or not 80d
and then ADHD and like trying this
medication and this and just like they
were trying to figure out just like I
was a kid who was you know didn't fit in
and didn't
wasn't paying attention
um
even when I was younger like I was
getting my when I was my dad coached all
like the the little league and the
basketball my brother was an athlete and
tried to get me into doing stuff and I
was just sitting in the Outfield like in
the playing in the dirt like I just
wasn't paying attention to things you
know
um
so I come in and I don't think I have a
reputation of this yet but my brothers
had a little bit of a reputation for him
being
I again I'll call it difficult because
I'm I'm remembering it through my eyes
as a kid I don't know but
he was in a different kind of tough than
me very smart but also whatever tough is
I wasn't in class with him I don't know
but I do remember I was intimidated to
go to this big school right like uh
I'm close enough with my brother but not
to where like he's gonna like put his
arm around me and be like hey if anyone
hurts Rick you know I'm gonna eat your
ass or whatever whatever you would do to
protect your kin
um but
one of the first days the first week of
school there was a class and I'm
remembering this maybe I'm a little off
this is how I remember it but a teacher
it's not gonna it's not as aggressive as
it sounds oh
push me up against the lockers
um it wasn't like he slammed me it was
more just like hey come here for a
second you know like
um if you I don't remember what he said
but like like something about me [__]
around if I'm anything like my brother
he's gonna blah blah blah blah blah
whatever that is like
hey I know your brother and you better I
don't know what my brother did if my
brother was wrong and anything I just
and from the beginning I had kind of
like this the way I remember it mark on
my back like I'm I'm a Glassman you know
I'm a smart ass uh and I was my own kind
of thing I'm sure too but from the
beginning eighth grade was always a bit
of a
what what's going on here I felt
overwhelmed what's going on that's I
would feel overwhelmed eighth grade
among guys that have beards and [__]
walking the hallways at 12th grade and
stuff they're driving like that's that
is weird to mix that young group of kids
eight years ago but it still feels yeah
you know like kind of recently yeah I
imagine I mean listen High School's been
forever go for me and it's still still
sits right there I don't gotta stay with
you yeah 33 years for you right Jesus
Christ
Jesus Christ anyway
um so so I'm uh I'm I'm in eighth grade
and I'm and I'm getting thrown against
lockers by teachers I'm a teacher yeah I
have no friends yeah
um I've already so bar mitzvahs are
still going on they start in seventh
grade they're still seven eight I grew
up shocker a lot of Jews edit that out
oh look at mine Cleveland has a lot of
Jews yeah Northeast Ohio is uh I grew up
in a very diverse area a lot of Jews a
lot of black people a lot of Asian
people I don't know what kind of Asian I
don't know if I could admit that but
just a lot of that
um and then there were some Christian
people
um but it was very like um
it was just a very diverse area uh and
Jewish people uh
a lot of Jewish people so there's just a
lot of bar mitzvahs like I don't 60 bar
mitzvahs maybe I am I made that number
up but like probably
um
so it's a thing every week There's a bar
mitzvah sometimes there's two
um
and seventh grade it started I was uh
I talk about this on stage sometimes but
like I was always very scared of girls I
never really knew how people felt about
me and I always assumed they feel about
me however I feel about me and I felt
insecure about it so I I knew everyone
knew whatever I was thinking and I was
scared and bar mitzvah's girls would ask
me to slow dance and I was too scared uh
so I always would make an excuse
oftentimes my mom's picking me up I
can't and then I would go outside for a
minute a few minutes and be like
because like I I thought they were going
to be watching me is his mom really
picking them up and then toward the end
of seventh grade definitely eighth grade
girls stopped asking me to dance
coincidence maybe
um so now I'm in this new school uh I'm
going to Bar Mitzvahs I'm feeling a
little not just the dancing it's kind of
a microcosm of just like
I was invited I even felt like oh I'm
invited to that they probably had to
invite me they're moms yeah I mean that
was like the mindset of me but are you
do you get along with your brother at
the time are you guys close can you
share things with him about these
insecurities in school and no I I like a
lot of brothers that I've heard of the I
love my brother he loves me
um and I don't mean that superficially
like I know that like if I needed to I
guess I could have oh I definitely know
that now but it was a pretty contentious
relationship the way I remember it
growing up like he was uh again he was
very smart and I would be asking him
questions and he would like
whatever I don't want to be mean about
it but we were kids you know but like I
was scared of him he you know he beat
the [__] out of me and like talk down to
me in a way that Brothers do and again
I'm sure I was annoying to him I I don't
know what his take on it was I just know
that as a kid I was scared of my brother
um so no
um
while also looking up to him you know
like he was popular and he played Sports
and he was funny and smart and
um girls would come over our house like
when he would have like little parties
kind of uh but in eighth grade I'm I'm
I'm feeling unincluded
enough it wasn't like I was so sad and
no one likes me I just I wasn't like I
didn't have a community I didn't feel
like I had a community and I don't even
know if I knew that then
um
and uh
teachers even like or like like don't
and I'm in this uh I'm in like like
whatever the learning disabled study
hall version would be
um and things kept going like I kept
getting kind of in trouble
um being annoying talking when I
shouldn't be uh not doing my homework
right the stuff that I'm sure 85 of
comedians would tell you
um but then I was in this CL this study
hall class and then they brought me to
and I still don't quite understand what
it's called but the way I think of it is
like there's the learning disabled study
hall and then there's the the the one
for like he's two disabled for this one
you know so they put me in this other
class which I don't know what this is
I've talked about this with people
before they don't have experience with
this it was this special class with kids
that it was like five kids in there
um
it was weird like
they they do you have questions am I
just talking too much I do have a
question yeah one question is what what
is the first learning disability
classroom just because you're our add
and acting out and stuff like it's
trouble but what is it you're not
getting or at least for them in this
school what are you being taught a
certain curriculum in this class
instead of going to study hall right
with 50 other kids or 20 other kids
whatever
um I would probably
um I guess is they thought I was gonna
disrupt them okay because that's what
I'm saying like how can you be
too dumb for a study hall yeah yeah it's
not it's not I think you call them
learning disabled so you don't call them
bad kids because they're not bad kids
there is a learning disability whatever
it is call it a disability but it's all
right this kid's not getting what we're
teaching it's yeah it's but disrupting
is going to be a thing yeah and that's
why I'm not getting it and that's why
I'm keeping them now you're going from
this class that you're disrupting these
kids who could get it and they're moving
you to another which I think was already
by default because like I I'm sure there
was stuff going on in seventh grade
before it's like Ricky's a little as you
would say do you have your Wallflowers
and your bad boys and then you have um
this is the guy that annoys everybody
what did you like about doing that I
didn't I didn't know I was doing it you
really didn't know I'm bored baby I want
to play right you know I I don't care I
didn't have the twist but you didn't
have a friend that you were [__]
around with this is all you by yourself
I'm sure I was [__] around with
people and probably I don't remember but
I have to imagine if anybody wanted to
play with me I'm gonna prioritize that
you know like you know doing jokes like
remember the penis game remember that
game no you would say um penis and then
it's your top and you have to the person
the next person has to say penis a
little louder
I know we never got that's good
you know and like and you're doing that
and I got friends
yeah that kind of [__]
no we never played the penis game but I
I like that people comments you know the
penis game I feel like people know about
that and you start off you start you
don't even have to say the game because
you know you just go like this like
you'd be over there so you want to be
the first person or the last yeah you
just go like this penis
and now you're gonna be like
a penis
um
but yeah it's just uh you get in trouble
a couple times I think they go it's a
public school they go put them in this
put put them in this Lovejoy my class
dude I will love that [__] I have a lot
of uh empathy for young me looking back
for how much I've thought about like oh
I was so annoying all the things and
just like man what a cute kid
what a cute kid to just all I wanted to
do was connect with people and the only
way I knew how to do that was I talked
about this on my pod but like I never
knew what people were thinking
um
I always knew laughs Bingo always knew
last hour of getting somebody to laugh I
always knew it um and believed it
somebody who'd make my brother laugh
when we were fighting or my parents when
I'm in trouble it does something it
it means something so that was like the
way to connect
um
so I'm in I'm obviously being too
disruptive to the other kids that are
mildly disruptive so they put me in this
other class where I'm in I'm in a uh I
started being in there for like one
period and then it got to the point
where I'm in there the whole school day
so I don't go to any classes I don't
really know what's happening
um I'll attribute that to just me being
you know I was eight years ago I don't
remember exactly but like me being a
young kid and uh eight years ago when I
when I uh whatever
um
so I mean the secret diploma was
probably still on the wall you know it's
only a few years ago yeah am I still on
the wall at home
um wait are they telling what my diploma
why are they telling your parents that
they're yeah so I'm in trouble I've
talked about this on my pod once and we
called my mom she's so funny about it
she my mom is my mom is still mad at
some kids that maybe you know that maybe
called me a name when I was in fifth
grade like she is team Rick
[__] those people I'm gonna come to that
school board and [__] run over that
super intent you know like that kind of
[__] yeah and
um
but I also don't know everything that's
happening they were tracking me
um
I didn't know this but like writing
things down like what Rick is doing and
and I found out toward the end of eighth
grade that like they were saying
that I stab myself you remember do you
remember you used to put
uh safety pins or thumbtacks through the
air through the dead skin on your
fingertips I did that all the time it
was the you know the late 2000s
uh some other [__] that they would say
that never happened I burned myself with
cigarettes and I was dangerous and I
never smoked a cigarette my life still
um
so like I had all these things that they
were saying about me that
I couldn't really defend because I
didn't even know that it was that was
happening
um they put me in a I'm in this class
all day what episode I talked about this
um
uh I had Bill burrow not too long ago
and I referenced this one thing I'm
about to say and now people are
commenting this all I I it's really
funny so maybe it's worth getting into
it more
I uh
I'm getting I feel like I'm just talking
too much now you're not are you kidding
me please so
I mean they're in this class I'm in this
class all day and I'm not how many other
kids are in there still five or whatever
maybe four or five none of them for my
grade none of them that I know really no
none of them that I knew that I could
remember none of them that I knew like
are you talking to them like why are you
in here or any of that [__] yeah it's
like what'd you do yeah no no I just I
didn't really get it I'm just like you
got to be in here I'm like all right I
didn't really get it I knew I didn't
like it
um I knew that I now wasn't going to any
other classes I knew with the same
teacher all day same teacher all day
there was her and then there was another
like sub teacher right like sub meaning
like the assistant teacher or whatever
and are they rotating through subjects
like we're doing a little math now but
no they're not teaching me we're sitting
there the whole day and now from this
for this period they gave me this
history book and so now I'm just
supposed to read it and then this period
I'm supposed to read this book I I don't
they're teaching you nothing yeah yeah
they're keeping me away from the people
that are getting what they need to get
out of the school
and
I'm also you know I'm not sitting there
you know like please swim oh I have some
soup you know I'm like
um you know I'm so [__] idiot
you know it's like walking around the
class
asking the kid that's probably 23 to buy
me a Playboy
that's weird I thought about that
recently like I'm almost I'm almost
Kevin's age
uh
they uh I was being so annoying to them
that they I'm in a desk like a classic
desk there's enough room there's a table
there but they put blue tape around it
and said I'm not allowed to step foot
out no dude yeah so I would give you a
perimeter
for a whole day for you know seven hours
perimeter So when you say you can't put
your foot out I'm like all right so I
I'm on my knees walking around the
classroom they hated you too they made
it little did they know that I would
soon be on an ABC show about a woman who
writes obituaries for dead people
[Music]
[Laughter]
hold on this is starts in eighth grade
this is still eighth grade still eighth
grade yeah and it's the whole year now
um
yeah
yeah you're not going home and saying
mom dad what the [__] they got me in
this room yeah I hate it and they're
like yeah well you know so I I'm under
the impression that just just like you
know like this is just something
this isn't a permanent thing
I I don't I don't remember
I don't remember
um I also don't know if I did ever know
I'm just like this is what I'm told I'm
supposed to do and my my mom's going in
and talking to the principal in school
going like this is what Rick has to do
it's like all right
um
before I was in that class the whole day
it was I'm in that class one period and
then like I'm in it for half and then I
get to go to some classes
there was a class and this is the story
I told to or the story I'm about to tell
is part of what I stole it with Bill
which is I remember I was in class it
was an English class I think it was in
English class doesn't matter I'm in
class and uh
they team us up so like there's no like
we're paying attention to the teacher
it's kind of a very loose free-for-all
you know like teachers at her desk doing
a thing and we're like we're working on
the thing they're working it's like
there's talking going on it's it's a
it's a a fun class and if I remember
correctly I didn't ask to use the
bathroom I think I just went to the
bathroom
and uh not to not to smoke a cigarette
or get blown I just went to take a piss
and I'm walking back and while I'm
walking back um before I you're walking
and then the class is here so I can't
see it but I could hear the teacher is
losing it yelling Ricky's on the loose
Ricky's on the loose
on the loose dude and I I remember this
I remember thinking as a as a as a
eighth grader I remember thinking
Ricky's on the loose what the [__] are
you talking about I didn't recognize
that oh they think I'm an animal I just
like what is what are you talking about
I I you know I'm not an idea I'll
probably wash my hands a good amount of
time
and I walked in and Rick and listen and
after that I I wasn't alone class
anymore I had to go back now I'm all day
in the thing and I still had for for a
little bit uh he's a friend of mine now
maybe he was then
but he for years he would say Ricky's on
the loose to me and I always thought it
was funny it wasn't like it wasn't yeah
it was just like oh [__] remember that
Ricky's on the loose
um so now I'm in this class the whole
day I don't get to go in the wash where
are you from a little more did you guys
go to Washington in eighth grade DC yeah
oh yeah every every grade yeah every
degree for the Midwest on over everyone
goes to DC in eighth grade that's like
the eighth grade trip
uh I didn't get to go and I remember I
was really sad I didn't get to go
because like I wanted to go I wanted to
be part of this thing I remember I never
I don't remember questioning why I'm in
this class what's going on but I do
remember please please please can I go
on this trip I remember asking this to
my teachers to my mom to talk to the
teachers the principal all the like I
really really really really want to go I
also was gonna be embarrassed like when
people said why aren't you there for me
to be like um I'm on the loose you know
like what am I gonna say
so I'm just like embarrassed and and
already wasn't included so now I'm like
I'm not I'm literally not even around
the people to get the organic like
what's up
um
and at the end of eighth grade
my uh I don't remember if they said this
to me or my my mom or both but I had an
uh an ultimatum so now ninth grade is
starting I'm gonna be in this class how
do I get out of this class how do I get
to have a school you know like
experience I said you could either stay
in this class or you could go to this
other school pep positive education
program
and then if you go to this school for
however long you go to then we'll decide
basically like the only way out is
through you have to go through pep
before you can come back to regular
school this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp getting to know yourself can
be a lifelong process especially because
we're always growing and changing
therapy is all about deepening your
self-awareness and understanding because
sometimes we don't know what we want or
why we react the way we do until we talk
through things so better help connect
you with the licensed therapist who can
take you on that journey of
self-discovery from wherever you are for
example it's helpful for learning
positive coping skills and how to set
boundaries it empowers you to be the
best version of yourself it isn't just
for those who've experienced major
trauma if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is a great
option it's convenient flexible
affordable and entirely online you just
fill out a brief questionnaire to get
matched with a licensed therapist and
you can always switch therapists anytime
for no additional charge if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
honeydew today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash honeydew manscaped is
here and they've got the tools to give
you the beautifully decorated eggs of
your dreams this Easter season get
yourself feeling as sweet as candy by
going to manscape.com and getting 20 off
plus free shipping with code honeydew
inside the performance package 4.0
you're gonna find the lawnmower 4.0
trimmer weed whacker 2.0 ear nose hair
trimmer crop preserver ball deodorant
crop reviver toner performance boxer
briefs and a travel bag to hold your
goodies the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer is an
elite electric trimmer with Advanced
Skin safe technology that is designed to
trim hair on loose skin the lawnmower
4.0 is also waterproof and equipped with
an LED light the weed whacker 2.0 nose
and ear hair trimmer helps reduce Nick
snack eggs and tugs and those delicate
nose and ear holes April is Easter but
it is also testicular cancer awareness
month manscape has partnered with the
testicular cancer society to bring
awareness to Men's Health and early
cancer detection manscaped is committed
to raising awareness for the most common
form of cancer in men age 15 to 35 and
giving support for fighter survivors and
families impacted by testicular cancer
as part of their we save balls
initiative save balls and save 20 off
and free shipping with the code honeydew
it manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with the code honeydew at
manscape.com hop into the best deal of
the year with manscaped now let's get
back to the do but man other than acting
out in class you've done nothing you
haven't assaulted a teacher like
anything beat the [__] out of a teacher
oh you could you imagine if you left
that out all this time but you have to
understand I'm I'm in eighth grade and I
don't know what's going on right
treating you like well they're treating
you like an animal there was a there was
a time I remember I don't remember where
I was walking but there was a teacher
that was like in charge of like
I don't know I just remember he was a
just a big dude and like whenever I went
to the bathroom he walked me
um
and he would
no no I'm being serious yeah
you better not be
yeah
it doesn't matter we need to report this
class into school
uh no he would um
he
uh walked me into the
bathroom and
when I was trying to take a [__] he
would go
quick you try to take a poopy
how far is it where I'm not making a
joke about this thing as opposed to
doing a performance you know
um no but he would walk me to the
bathroom like not in but live because
yeah I don't know I don't know but did
you ever do that did you ever leave the
school or anything like why I wasn't a
bad kid I was an annoying kid also fair
enough weird not fair to even say
because what defines bad I guess that is
I I wasn't
I wasn't breaking things I wasn't I
wasn't hurting people
um
but I think they were like well we don't
know I've had friends describe me as a
loose cannon like that didn't want me to
feature for them you know and I was as
an adult so
you know I'm sure these teachers like we
don't know what the [__] this kid's
gonna do
before I did anything one of them's
throwing me up against the locker and
yeah don't be like your brother you
didn't even you got two steps the
Jeopardy champion
[Laughter]
most likely to win Jeopardy don't be
like him
um
but there was one time I could remember
and I don't think it's that big of it
could you hear me where I um uh I'm
walking I'm walking to the bathroom and
I had a book and I'm like throwing it up
in the air and catching it and uh I did
throw it up in the air and it went a
little forward and I think it landed on
his head or his shoulder or something
Whoo Kid the the guy that was
responsible for walking me to the
bathroom oh [__] and I I remember they
thought and I get it like here's the
skin like it was an accident but it was
I um he's like he's throwing books at me
like um he stabs himself so I had tough
act into an actin for athlete's foot you
turn it upside down like canned air
stuff comes out you did on your hand you
see this Mark and then it goes away yeah
uh I had a little circle on my hand the
next day and they uh I never knew this
until after they said I'm burning myself
with cigarettes I'm stabbing myself I'm
throwing books at teachers Ricky's on
the loose so they're creating a
narrative about this kid who's just
annoying but you yeah now all of a
sudden you're causing harm to yourself
yes and others you're hitting people
with books and I'm sure if anybody was
like well let's take a look at this they
go in the room and I'm on my knees like
I'm not touching the floor with my feet
you know it's on top of my case inside
your blue tape
Okay so
so like all right pep it is
Pepe is this now ninth grade yeah so
ninth grade starts
and I got my ear pierced
you know I'm a bad boy do we have a
stutter we dangling what are we doing in
ninth grade stuff yeah okay I mean I
don't know I guess you're from the 80s
but we didn't do dangling stuff though
really 73 this is when like the office
is out you know and British no America
oh okay this is two thousand you know
okay just checking Nate's here just
checking
um I guess technically it was 95 or
2015.
um but I got into the office late
again we're in pep now yeah ninth
Christian I was 2016. and how does that
differ than what you were in the eighth
grade class are you still taped you
don't know about pep no I don't know
about that dude listen I'll be honest I
would walk by those classes and look in
and see five kids yeah one would be in a
wheelchair and I'd wonder why the other
four were even in there yeah well two of
them are chewing on the other one's feet
but yeah
I yeah yeah I used to walk by those
classes this is Pep yeah this is a
school for it not the class this is a
school this is so you're no longer no
I'm not going to my school I'm getting
bust to Euclid okay yeah all right um
which is when you go to Cleveland to do
hilarities I'm sure you could drive it's
right around there
um I'm you know
I'm not at my hometown
um
was great by the way it just happened to
be where it is I think it was there can
we talk about that for a little
um
no no so so now I'm going to the school
and I'm like okay so eighth grade I go
into this new school I'm nervous ninth
grade I'm doing it again but I also am
like
what's happening I remember feeling like
what's what's what's happening what am I
doing
I felt this feeling many times in my
life
what's not matching up with what's my
intentions are and what's going on in my
head with the world around me what the
[__] is happening why am why am I here
it also scared me it also scared me for
two reasons one I don't want to have to
stay here and two I was scared in this
school with these kids that I was also
typecasting as bad kids good point I
just remember thinking ultimately I
ended up making friends with some of
these kids but when you first go in it's
like you know if Mr Carter were rated R
is that your time yes it is it's like
[__] you teach you know that kind of
stuff like that stuff is happening
people are saying that [__] really oh
yeah it was on the first floor but still
kids were kids were trying to escape
they were going out the window they were
on the loose they were they were on
still I'm not on the loose I'm I'm um
I'm I don't need tape you know I'm right
here but also you don't know going into
school like what do I need to do to get
out of here and back to the right I knew
be good that's it yeah which but you
don't know if you're there for the whole
year a semester or no more until I
graduate no because oh [__] so at first
I thought I'll go here for a little and
then I'll be out but then while I'm in
there for a little bit I'm seeing like
oh these kids like these kids have been
here for years like this is just like
you know this is what this is the school
now
and I knew to be good and and why didn't
I know to be good before I don't exist
classroom now you're regular classroom
size also I mean it's a full school it's
um it's it's just a different school oh
[__] so there's all it's not just a room
no no it's it's a different school where
there's a whole bunch of classrooms for
all the different ages all the different
grades it's just kind of like um in
stranger things it's just a different
school now it's just this is where you
know the demigods grow up got it um am I
using that word right
is a demigod
um but you're asking a wrong dude right
um
so I'm in class it's like a it's a
regular class you know 15 kids in there
you gotta but you got a teacher you got
the assistant teacher and you got your
restrainer the restrainer is there for
when kids are jumping out the window and
you know the teacher or the other kids
or something
um
you go to the bathroom there's
oftentimes somebody running down the
hallway and a teacher tackling tackling
them and then you're just uh and it
wasn't weird after a little bit it
really wasn't like you go into the
bathroom you go
you just keep getting tackled get the
[__] off teach
you know what I'm just remembering dude
at your school I'm just remember and it
really became a norm soon it's it's
interesting you know it's it's not mob
mentality but that same psychology of
like when you're when something is
unusual it's unusual but when it becomes
the status quo it is what it is and you
adapt quickly and and there's so many
things that are shocking to us and this
is something I learned when I came into
some self-awareness uh like maybe six or
so years ago which was
my behavior your behavior the world
around us that scares us or makes us
confused or uncomfortable oftentimes
isn't the issue it's that it didn't meet
our expectations oftentimes our
subconscious expectations so we're kind
of shut off but once like this is what
it is it's like oh this is what it is
and it's I think a big tool set of
learning to adapt is to accept the fact
that like
this thing isn't always
a problem you just have to recognize
oftentimes it could be but just like
what it isn't and I did adapt quickly
to this world for a couple reasons one
it I knew this it felt like the eighth
grade before is like it was all building
up to this it wasn't out of nowhere
um and two uh I got kind of scared
straight like you don't want to be silly
you're silly when you want to connect
with people you know if you don't want
to do that if you don't like
so I shut down you know I was just like
this and uh I am remembering a time
because I was thinking about the hallway
I don't think I've ever told this story
maybe but
I had real bad obsessive compulsive
disorder as a kid
um
and it comes in and out time to time one
thing that translates over that I think
people even without OCD could connect to
is you don't want to sit on a public
toilet seat
um you wipe it down you fold a whole
bunch of stuff what you squat whatever
your whatever your thing is but I
remember I went to the bathroom and
either I didn't have time or I didn't
want to put the toilet paper down or
whatever and I and I [__] and missed the
toilet and got
um on my pants
so I'm now in this special school
[__] my pants you know like if
you're in prison and you [__] your pants
like a [__]
so I remember I remember I [__] in my
pants by the way
while my pants are down you know yeah
it's not like it's like it's like just I
just missed yeah so like not an athlete
and I remember I remember like I
remember I remember talking myself the
most adult I'd ever been at this point
was when I [__] in my pants and I go
Rick here's what we're gonna do you know
I I went back in time and I'm talking to
him now here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna go to the we're gonna go to the
office we're gonna call Mom we say mom
bring me some pants I'm gonna go back to
the bathroom I'm gonna wait an hour and
I did that and I and I remember walking
down the hallway
dodging kids getting tackled just hoping
they don't see the back of my pants
hey Mama I I put my also poor my mom who
had to deal with my kids my kids not bad
and I was like hey Mom I poop my pants
you know I was like
and I'm 14 by the way I'm not nine
kids are literally getting blown my
friend kids are getting blown pre-ninth
grade and I'm dodging I'm dodging the
tackled kids so my mom brought me some
pants
and uh yeah so in the school and
yeah I I I I'm really grateful for it I
it's I I started playing basketball
because of it because like you want to
play basketball and like I'm in my
khakis and whatever but like yeah I
played basketball and and then when I
got to go back to school I remember my
buddy Tim said do you play basketball
and I said yes because I played four
times over at Pep
um
and that like changed my life basketball
changed my life
um how
I I was part of a community which the
only time I experienced that before this
was uh playing Magic the Gathering where
every Friday nights I would go down to
the card store and it would Friday Night
Magic so like there was a group of
people I was with every week but I
wasn't friends with them I didn't feel
like I was friends with them but I
always had a place to go so there's this
community of people that played Magic
they weren't my friends though
uh this was a community where like we
all have a common goal we all like this
thing you know if I do well you do well
um we're rooting for each other it's
competitive it lets you get it like I
was um I was a kid that that I that
people didn't want to come over because
I always thought my brother they were
scaring my brother because my brother's
very aggressive but I didn't consider
the fact that I'm also like forcing them
to choreograph lightsaber fights and
wrestling and boxing my brother got
boxing gloves because we're big in a
rocky
and I'm like you want a box and like no
I'm like this is box like I would make
them box me so like I was very
aggressive and wanting to fight not
fight but you know what I mean like
wrestle and and just uh get aggression
out and be physical and and basketball
offered that
um prior to that you had never played
any records organized stuff but I wasn't
interested you know I wasn't interested
I I I uh I liked magic I play the piano
um the only thing I could think of
classes was taking dance class at The
JCC for a year in seventh grade yeah
like the Jews would go and so you could
learn the Cotton Eye Joe and the you
know whatever whatever the the things
were
um you know a lot of Drake was coming
out at that time
[Music]
Undateable it just gotten canceled
who was more Undateable than this guy
I'm
sure so I wasn't good at basketball but
like I I
have friends I stayed after school and I
wanted to be I loved it I loved it and I
wanted to get good at it I remember
doing layup lines I remember this
intimately because like I remember
thinking back oh look how far I've come
layup lines are just a warm-up thing you
you have people on the left you have
people on the right people on the right
you go you do a layup on the left they
get the rebound they pass this person
right so you're practicing uh Outlet
passes driving to the hoop then when you
have to go to the left side I was I was
so scared because I couldn't make a
left-handed layup and you would do it
and you would do it and and you'd shoot
and look back to see if you made like
please please don't miss this like like
it mattered it's like a new school I'm
in where it's like don't [__] up
so like I have this new tool where I
knew that I could [__] up and that's
yeah tell me about that I had this
luxury growing up where I didn't know
how other people saw me
and
I also had the luxury of having a very
loving family very supportive parents
applauding me how funny I am how great I
am play the piano for me I would do
interpretive dance for my mom and she's
like I want to see you know it's a
Jewish mom who just loves her boy
um I'm the best
uh I thought I was
um and I'm glad I thought I was because
it uh
what's the difference between thinking
you're the best and you suck but also
thank God you had that at home because
your entire [__] educational system
is trying to push you down and tell you
you aren't [__] and you're a problem and
you should be over here you're this
weird outlier and we don't know what to
do with you but you got unconditional
love at home so thank God could you
imagine if your parents I thought about
that in the same way as I thought about
yours how much that gotta [__] you up
because I knew the school was wrong
whether I was right or not at the time I
knew it I'm awesome I'm a great kid
so them telling me what I am couldn't
change my identity but because what I
had at home so the opposite even if
you're great and you're doing great but
your people at home are telling you
you're not and if that's your identity I
I mean I I've thought about I could get
them emotional about analysis like I
want you [__] sucks the the cards
that people are dealt with like you're
told who you are before you figure it
out and how much work it is to like kind
of change that I talk about on stage now
sometimes well said I'm a I'm a Jewish
Democrat because my parents are so like
yeah I don't know I guess that's what I
am I don't care I don't know uh
and I've talked about how like you have
to know so much to change the way you
see things from a kid like Ari shaffir
grew up super Jewish super the only the
only people who aren't Jewish anymore
almost became a rabbi like you have to
learn so much to decide maybe this isn't
for me most of the time this is
sufficient whatever I'm yeah I'll vote
for Biden I don't know I don't know
anything dude me either but like no it's
our identities it's it's you know
culturally I'm Jewish more than I am of
like needing to know like what to do on
Passover it's just yeah I'm Jewish I got
you know I got arthritis and I'm funny
you know it comes with the territory 22
and arthritis
um that's early that's early onset
arthritis I I did get arthritis very
early
um and whenever you're laughing at just
also know that is true I got arthritis
very early but whatever whatever
Universe are staying alive what the [__]
to believe but no I didn't I've had I've
had shoulder surgery uh elbow surgery
triple hernia surgery from my arm's
tired yeah
why hernia surgery from arthritis uh
well the uh no no just saying just like
I got a Jewish body got it you know this
is your list of elements uh I just think
it made me stronger
and um
so wait what were we talking about
talking about how the identities yeah
yeah so so so
um
so I think I'm great and then I find out
that even if I think I'm great I'm still
getting in trouble what's going on
um
and in basketball
I now want something at the time I
thought that I want to make the JV team
but looking back is I wanted to be able
to keep playing with kids I wanted to
keep
I wanted to develop friendships I wanted
to be part of something I loved being
part of something I still love being
part of something
stand up is the same thing I fell in
love with stand up
because
look what we got all good I never
thought of stand-up as a lonely isolated
thing I still don't I also don't tour
that much on on my own it's not an
isolated thing look at this you know
this isn't stand up yeah but it's yes it
is it's comedy it's stand up it's not
but may I tell you my experiences sure I
moved and then we'll go back if there's
time and you want to hear more but I
moved to Los Angeles with this with a
skill set basketball I find out about
comedy store has basketball team there's
Ren is easy and Matt nost and Ari
shaffir and and all these guys who are
like have been doing comedy for a while
who were playing basketball and I get to
come in and I'm like I'm a new comedian
they don't know me but like I'm a pretty
good basketball player so now I have
peers and going to The Comedy Store on
Sundays trying to get on potluck maybe I
do maybe I don't if I don't you wait for
three hours I'm sitting there with
Santino with Brady Matthews with Brian
Moses
um
we're just doing this where I'm hanging
out you uh Melissa via Senor Sandy Danto
Benji aflalo like all these people that
like
uh Esther brovitsky like I'm just
remembering like we would go and go to
diners or sit and try to get up or
complain about not getting up or you go
to IO open mic it was this it was
friends I wasn't going driving to The
Comedy Store parking up at my aunt and
uncle's place to walk down because like
I gotta [__] work on this three
minutes
you know I was I was going because like
who's gonna be there I remember I
remember I all I did was play basketball
from ninth grade on all my free time yes
I did on my own and I would like to want
a set of cones I would do that stuff
because if I had to but
I remember the local JCC is is where we
would go if we couldn't get into the
school
um and I remember that feeling of going
I remember the feeling of going and
parking and holding my indoor shoes and
walking fast like who's here
it wasn't about playing it's who's here
friends it's always about friends
um and in comedy more specifically than
friends or in addition to friends it's
also about collaboration it's also like
playing and doing and yeah wrestling you
know like fighting oh I do agree with
that yes so yeah I don't think of stand
up as lonely and isolating that three
minutes I'm on stage I don't even think
that way because first starting out you
want to make your friends in the back
laugh yeah
um
it's friendship man like like it's
I'm feeling myself getting like a little
emotional about it now because like
what's better than laughing with people
you know and
more specifically when you're not
laughing with people like you don't have
them and I know logically that's not
true anymore I used to think that I just
like I I better be funny that's also
where I felt my value was and where I
was too much it's like gotta be funny I
I want these people to like me so I
better be funny yeah could tell me more
about that I just mean you know it took
me a long time to get to this point
where I could sit with people and have
real human conversations because all I
wanted to do was make you laugh I'm not
a um
I'm not really in among the comedy we're
on I wouldn't consider myself an extra
extrovert I never really hung out at the
clubs or anything I always felt like
um I could be doing something else or
should be working harder If instead of
hanging here I should be home writing
and getting better or do whatever it was
but it was also an excuse not to have to
be around people where I didn't feel
comfortable all the time then how are
you trying to make them laugh that kind
of contradicts that well making a making
a an audience of strangers laugh is
different than making our peers laugh
you got to sit there and talk and have
conversation with these people and try
to make them laugh in this conversation
versus a captive audience who well these
days with Tick Tock they're all talking
back but you know sits there and listens
to what you have to say and you command
a room there's a different way of making
those people laugh that's all about your
value you're just saying your value is a
stand-up comedian they're not as a human
no I mean I just always thought that one
of the things that I had as a value was
being able to make people laugh at their
worst times at their best times it just
was something I felt like well if
there's nothing I can bring to this
situation I can probably make you laugh
what do you mean as in pros and cons
what's the problem with that well the
problem with that is I always don't feel
comfortable doing that and I don't never
felt like I felt fit in somewhere but
this is just when you're on stage no
this is in comedy in general because you
said you but you're not I'm just
confused because you said you're not
hanging out you're not doing this with
people yeah it didn't so then
how are you what I'm confused then about
what
for me my value is as a person like
that's why I would do it to all the
people and be annoying and like need
always be on but you're saying you
weren't that um
but I knew I had this thing because I
would it would be like that seems
healthy
I don't know if it is it's it's
um I hear what you're saying but like
give me I'll give you an example my
friends
um sister was dying in the hospital when
we were in high school and she and a
good friend of ours were in a car
accident they pass away I'm in the I'm
not on a stage I'm not hanging around a
bunch of comedians but we're in a
hospital waiting room and I'm making
people laugh yeah and I'm making them
feel good so that's what I mean there's
a scenario there where it's the toughest
thing you could have to go through and
it's not a stage it's not a bunch of
comedians trying to make each other
laugh I'm realizing that I have this
superpower I was about to say not yes I
realized that I have this thing and I
don't always feel good using it you know
what I mean like it's conflicting to me
until I get into this world of Comedians
and then I'm like okay but I still don't
feel like it took me 20 years to become
a regular at the comedy store could you
get me in
oh you were talking to the right lady
you were talking to the right lady I got
merch uh I went uh I have merch um let
me pull it up he's got merch yes for
real um also keep talking unless you
think it's true or I'll put this up but
no could you give an example of I get it
when you're in the hospital and you
don't feel comfortable using it even
though you did but could you give an
example of when do you not feel
comfortable using it
because that just seems like restraint
I know longer I don't I feel comfortable
using it all the time now I didn't at
first it was like this
not bad
a picture
[Laughter]
took me forever dude took me forever but
I'm there now but also I wonder if I'd
have been there hanging out more
um ingratiating myself in these people's
lives and worlds and making them laugh
and feel this and that if I wouldn't
have got anywhere faster I don't know
right
um but I've always been the guy that was
I'm gonna go in there I'm gonna say
hello to everybody that's nice to me I'm
not gonna go out of my way to go up to
anybody and say hey I'm a big fat I just
I've always felt but you wanted to you
wanted more but you were insecure yeah
100 so then I go up to on stage and
again even with this insecurity I'm
strong about this I feel good about this
because I don't know these people I'm
not making small talk with you I'm just
you know vomiting my thoughts jokes
ideas on you to see if it's funny or not
and I don't relate to you right
I have you stand up by the curtain and
just having you throwing up on an
audience
um
and that's what I was always comfortable
with which is again still distant yeah
even though you're there in this room
full of 400 people or whatever it is and
then I don't hang out I boom off into
the night you want to hang out yeah no I
do and I don't I want to say hello to
the right people the nice people the
people you're the right no just the ones
that are good to me and I'm comfortable
with that probably are as awkward as I
am and get that feeling you know yeah
I'm not I've never been a social
butterfly you know I see those guys that
go in and they're like hey what's up and
they know everybody
dapping everybody up in 20 minutes in I
just kind of like the float by I like to
walk by that right and go into like me
after I share my pants going down the
hallway of restrained kids exactly but
I'll sit in the green room with
everybody that's on there and hang have
a green room hang that I'm comfortable
with the rest of it I've never gone to
diners and hung out with me at best I
never did that stuff so my best friends
now because of that and basketball those
are that's that that's the battlefield
Sports I'm still friends with I was just
talking about this with a friend of mine
I'm still friends with so many people
from middle school and high school which
is really unique and rare so I mean I
could probably count 20 of them and all
of those people go back to Sports youth
sports high school sports like I I
really did it's interesting I hear you
say comedy's not but to me comedy is
like tennis you're out there by yourself
performing and then when you're done you
don't really we don't really see well
podcasts have helped that but other than
that we wouldn't really see each other
unless we're on the same show or we're
all at a festival together when you when
you were doing comedy here had you
already been established did you start
out started here right so I get it now
now that we're we have these wildly
successful podcasts and we're super rich
and famous
yeah but like
now that like people are touring and
doing their own thing it is different
now but the first five plus years
yes unless you're at a show together but
I'm always at a show together I'm always
at a show and I see Amir K or you know
uh uh Brent Morin like you're always
seeing somebody same with playing
basketball like who's gonna be here
today I don't know which of the seven
people of this pool of 35 will be here
but there's always someone so
you didn't do that no I would look at a
lineup and see who's on and be like okay
I know that person I can at least say hi
to that person and sit near them and be
comfortable them I don't know these four
people I'll say hello and I'm Ryan nice
to meet you that's probably it unless
you strike up conversation then I'm all
in then I'm all in yeah I will um
but I'm not the guy that usually now
these days I definitely am back then no
not at all I feel
comfortable in my own skin now it's not
just about do I feel like I'm good
enough to be in this room I know I'm
good enough to be in that room is that
what kept you before maybe I'm not good
enough yeah maybe I'm not good enough
maybe
um I mean except me from life you know I
but I always knew I was I always knew
that anything I did sports or whatever I
would if I if I really school if I put
time and effort into it I would excel at
it I knew that so I knew about comedy
the thing I knew about comedy in my life
was
of all the things that I do I'm more
right about comedy than I am wrong about
comedy I can't say that about I mean
like if I think something's funny my
batting percentage is is higher always
on the right side than the Lower Side
even if it's 60 40. it's still something
that I'm like this is gonna be funny to
people people are gonna think this is
really funny
um I can be right about that more than
I'm wrong about that and I can't say
that about math I can't say that about a
lot of other things I've done in my life
um
what's 60 plus 40 100 looks like you're
pretty good at it
you know math bro the damn wink to the
camera right now and giving me
I think you know what you're doing
you laughed when I said 31 years ago you
believe 31 plus 18s what are you 52 51
bro 31 plus 18 is 51. is it 31 plus oh
it's 49. you know what I do with that I
do uh to do 31 plus 18 I do 31 plus 20
minus two yeah you do that no you do
it's a little trick sometimes my
daughter's doing math like that
sometimes you could do 31 plus 8 is 39
plus 10 is 49 but I find just round up
to the nearest uh five and then subtract
well you learn different math because
you were born what year were you born in
I don't understand the question no I'm
just kidding I'm just kidding I've been
waiting to get you no no uh you've had a
long time it's I'm 23 this year so so
two thousand but you're 23 and 23 yeah
of course yeah it's always been easy to
figure that out too because it's like
how old am I oh what year is it
yeah
man I remember [__]
anyway I don't want to get into it it's
just it's such a generational Gap so let
me let's get back to because I want to
wrap this up here when do you ever get
out of this [__] school yeah I want
to get out of school I got a half days I
got to do half days at this pep and then
I would for the second half of the day I
would go back to school
why why I only have reintegration so
let's see we'll give him a half day okay
so is this 11th grade you spend the
whole 10th grade in pep no no ninth
grade ninth just ninth grade just
because you started the first half a
year of ninth grade I was all pep and
then the second half of ninth grade I
was half days okay and then 10th grade
or end of ninth grade yeah that was back
at the original school yeah yeah okay
um and then 10th grade you're all fully
integrated back to the regular school in
ninth grade I got uh I was playing
basketball and one of the teachers had a
ring on and accidentally hit me
um playing basketball like just the way
you get hit
um I gotta had a like a mark right under
my eye I think it was mine it was my
forehead
I remember I wanted to go I asked could
I go to the school
that I'm not in
in case I get out in time to take the
yearbook picture so I could be in the
yearbook I always loved the yearbook
because I loved going around asking
people to sign stuff because I loved
going home and reading it people are
always night no one is like [__] you you
[__] yeah yeah you're right dork you
know it was always like have a great
summer yeah I was like okay I T yeah uh
what's Kit keep in touch oh
I didn't know that one yeah and um and
then like there's a girl I'd have a
crush on like you get to be able to talk
to him for a sec
um and my Euro picture has like this big
mark on me uh from The Ring yeah but I
got to get back in time uh for uh for
schooling and um
I was so embarrassed going back where'd
you go they would ask me
um I just went to I was trying out a
different school I didn't tell anybody
um but then they they the the school
like looked at me as like a a great
example of what could be and they
invited me back like hey you know for
the graduating class of that year like
they're gonna do uh an assembly and like
that they do every year for graduation
and would you please me Rick would you
please come and play the piano
um and like show them look what Rick did
and I'm like yeah I'll go I'll come play
the piano but did the school that you
went to have anything to do with the
help the piano playing
oh they just knew I played the piano
right
but they're making it does it am I wrong
is it making it sort of sound like look
look what Rick went away and did I don't
think so man and now he's coming here to
play for look at this this guy who used
to throw books of teachers is now a
concert pianist right because of us
right because of us
um I don't think so did you play I
played play Titanic and
and they had a choir and they learned
the song and they sang it but we never
rehearsed together the Celine Dion song
yeah My Heart Will Go On yeah so I'm now
here you never rehearse together oh no
not one time which incidentally I did
with uh I had Josh Groban on my podcast
and played the piano we never rehearsed
I played that and also spoiler alert if
you haven't seen it great episode I I
got a a a concert cellist and and P and
a violinist I'm on the second floor this
was during covert so we're doing
everything on the balcony Josh Groban
who I just met that day is on the
balcony windows closed in a tuxedo I'm
in the air conditioning you know my
place in sweats and on the first floor
and I have cameras out there there's a
chalice and a violinist and and black
attire you know a dress in suit
we play Titanic never had rehearsed uh
and it sounded great so I was prepping
for this my whole life
um pepping for this but I go in and yeah
I remember even thinking then like I'm
playing the piano and now there's a
squire singing My Heart Will Go On And I
also didn't know everything like oh
sorry
and they're just singing through it and
I just remember even then thinking like
what the [__] is this and they go ladies
and gentlemen you know like Rick
Glassman I go up on thing and they give
me this thing where the pen and has my
name engraved on it it's just like
whatever pen
um I remember thinking even then like
all right you know like all right I
guess I graduated from this [__]
traumatizing experience and then I go
back to school and then like I was
so well behaved for like a semester
um I got really bad grades except for
that semester I was a I don't know as a
Dean's List or honor roll whatever and I
just remember thinking like
teachers being like look what you could
do if you apply yourself I mean that was
the first time I remember that I'm like
oh yeah but then you know you don't want
to anymore
um but then I come back and now I have
basketball and that changed everything
because
I wasn't popular but now I have friends
I'm being invited places I'm I'm doing
this thing and I started really getting
confident uh I got confident because
you're yeah you just you're playing with
people and then I got pretty good at it
in college and that's where I met all my
friends you play basketball in college
no I I like even intramural intramural
um and just intramural and like
you know I thought I could make the team
you know I tried out College Kent State
Okay and like I tried out and and uh you
know I'm art
that just felt like I just felt cool
like I was playing with the team
sometimes and like the team would come
in and play an intramural and I remember
playing against the football team
Antonio Gates uh I was on the basketball
team then but like uh Josh cribs like
people who like who are professional
athletes now I remember playing in
and they were dunking and I was dunking
and I felt like look it and they thought
I was cool I don't know if they thought
it was cool but I remember thinking like
I'm one of these guys you can dunk yeah
how tall are you six three that's
[__] good right now you know it's I
haven't played in a little bit
um I think I still could uh yeah you're
only 22. uh yeah I just haven't played
it's weird that Antonio Gates and Josh
cribs were also there Duncan um Antonio
Gates wasn't on the football team
he was just on the basketball team yeah
I did know that for a while I think uh
he didn't start playing football until
his senior year maybe or something late
it was late for Antonio Gates he was a
beast on the basketball court yeah
that's true
um
and uh I also remember
uh you know Teddy Ginn Jr for Iowa State
he was uh he would come he came to the
JCC sometimes and I didn't know much
about football so but I know people like
that's Teddy again and like I looked him
up
um or my I was watched it I don't
remember but I saw since I'm like cool
and you'll come play and we were on the
same team and this was um uh I'd
probably been Duncan for like two years
or so now so I say that because like it
takes time to learn how to do stuff
um how comfortable am I doing this in a
game that's not a fast break do you try
because if you miss like there's still
like a um there's like a universe of
like unless you're jumping out of the
gym which I wasn't
how do I implement this because What
dunking means is you're cool that's what
it means yeah tell me about what that
[__] feeling must be like to be able
to dunk in front of Antonio Gates like
well the guys that do it at the top
level of their job it felt like it felt
like uh it felt like I belong here
am I a professional athlete you don't
need to tell me imagine I'm 5 10. I can
only imagine what it must be like to be
on a fast break and dunk in a gym at The
JCC in front of well no at the school
listen at Kent State at least when I
went there um a few years ago uh
um I uh I just graduated this year last
year
um
it's a big basketball school the rec
center has Four Courts you have uh one
that's volleyball and then you have the
C Court that's like if there's a lot of
people people are shooting around the B
Court which is packed
um and people aren't as good and then
the a court
um and then you have people waiting and
I would go and then there were times
where there's people waiting where
people who were next like ooh glasses
like people would wait like sorry I
already got my five but you didn't
really you had three you know
um and I'll get and there's a lot of
people both waiting to go on and on the
track watching you know like the the the
the teams the the actual schools teams
are there playing like it's a there's an
audience
so when you dunk and it's you know the
guy in the goggles and uh uh who's white
and then like people going nuts it's you
want that you know it feels really good
remember the first time I dunked on
somebody was at the JCC fast breaks it's
very cool but the first time I dunked on
somebody and it was a guy who like we
had beef with kind of I don't know why
but you know you just like [__] this guy
and everything remember I dunked on him
and felt
you know um but like I didn't say
anything to him I felt that felt like
act like you've been here before I
remember having that but all my friends
are like holy [__] and everything like
just be cool cool cool cool I want to
think this is what I do you know
um so then I get I start to figure out
like you know uh fast breaks it's easier
you know but in a drive if I get by
somebody it seems like you're dunking if
I could get a step through my side
you're not on them but like I could come
from this way and I started to get
decent at it and then I'm with Teddy I'm
playing I'm on Teddy's team and you get
this little there's a little extra
stand up in basketball it's like when
you're
doing stand-up and you have and you're
in the zone because like you're
auditioning and you get that first laugh
or whatever it is like you get this
adrenaline where like you go in that's
what happens when black teenagers are
watching you play basketball like
there's like you want them their
approval
let alone black Ohio State football
players and I threw him an oop and he
caught it and he dunked now we're equals
so yeah so I said throw me one and he
did and I dunked and he's going nuts and
now since then I well at least for a
while I'm now catching Hoops I'm dunking
easier it's just like it's really like I
could do it now and so now I'm playing
with this guy and I'm we're just dunking
all over the [__] place maybe it was
an inch low I don't think so but I just
remember thinking I've never jumped so
high in my entire life I got his phone
number I texted him a couple times he
texted back once and um
yeah just it's now I'm confident I I'm
people think I'm cool I don't know if
they do people want me on their team
sometimes they do and also I was so
aggressive and and like that's why I
have arthritis everywhere like you're
fighting and you're pushing like fights
like fist fights with people or even
friends like you're just pushing each
other and
and you're doing this and then when
you're done playing it's all everything
is good everything is all good I um
one thing I'll plug that I'm sure if
people I've plugged in enough so it's
this I made this character piece called
I am phenomenal this basketball thing I
made that was based off a true story of
getting kicked out of a basketball game
recently for being too aggressive you
did yeah
um uh my old boss uh Bill Lawrence again
I've talked about it fast forward uh I
was in this basketball game it's how I
got Undateable I got in this basketball
game first he asked me to audition
um Brent Morin and I both and I'm in it
for years and then he sent me an email
that was this inciting incident to like
so much self-awareness that I came into
was hey some of these guys don't want to
play with you here's the reasons blah
blah blah
um and I ended up making these things on
my YouTube it's awesome I filmed it
actually because I was writing something
and I wanted to edit it to kind of find
some stuff I never thought I was going
to share it I ultimately ended up
filming a new ending to it last year and
like hey put it out like kind of
Frankenstein this thing together it's
funny it's it's good but like the script
Joel McHale plays Bill Lawrence and the
script is that Joel script is directly
from the email bill sent me so it's this
very cool experience of like me playing
this version of myself it's too much but
basically the idea is I'm playing with
these comedy writers and guys that are
just want to have a good time like cut
to the [__] hoop you know and like
doing bits and yelling and aggressive
and not passing enough and just come
he's like [__] you know just we don't
want Rick here anymore
um but like
that's where I grew up where you get to
connect with people like this idea no no
we're just playing ball because when
you're in college the goal is to not
lose because if you lose you you have to
wait an hour and a half to play next
that's all that mattered was winning
here you people people when they win
they go like take my spot I need a break
it wasn't about that but I had that same
intensity
um and there's two things as being funny
was my value in basketball is my value
so I I kind of shoved it down people's
throats and I didn't realize Rick just
be here you know what I mean
um anyway there's more but I'm getting
wrapped up on how much we're talking
dunking uh when you first got it that
adrenaline dunking in front of the
football players
what what's been more of a Adrenaline
Rush crushing a stand-up set or that you
know the answer to that I couldn't
imagine there's not dude especially when
like I didn't get to play much you know
yeah and I wanted to be good we had a
really good team uh I've talked about
this before too but we played against
LeBron a couple years you did yeah and
we and we got to you're out on the court
with that massive man uh I have a cool
picture where uh where we're on the
we're uh on the opposite ends of the
foul line together it was it's it's it's
like um
I wanted to be part of that more you
know because I just started playing I
got to play against him but I wasn't
part of the team really I was in a few
minutes in that game I mean I was part
of you know what I mean like I wasn't I
wasn't part of what helped drive this
team and uh
I wanted to be and you want to be
included ice ice dunked for the first
time a week after senior year basketball
ended
I was in the gym with one of these guys
that were really good the Jones triplets
uh they were six six black guys dad Jim
Jones played you know the Lakers and the
Cavs like they're great and we was like
helping me showing me how to get off the
my my how to jump basically and then I
dunked and he's like yeah and I would go
in the hall and bring in people to watch
me done bleeding yeah watch this watch
this the confidence you have to have
imagine imagine I'm about to go on stage
and I go up to people that I know that
much hey come in here you're going to
want to see this imagine that kind of
confidence you don't have that you know
even if you did that kind of ruins it
so being able to do that thing
especially when people know you can't do
it especially you do it in a game where
it's also mad on someone too yeah
there's only a couple times I did on
somebody but like like I said next to
like you know it still could look like a
poster if you're from the side
there's nothing like it also because
maybe there is for people that do that
all the time but like I wanted that I
wanted
dunking on somebody meant on being
included getting people to also getting
approval yes yes
getting a laugh
isn't that for me sometimes maybe but
when I get a laugh on stage and I know
I'm being funny I think yeah and if I
don't get a laugh and I know I'm being
funny I'm like that's funny
I want them to like me but that's not
going to dictate that doesn't change me
dunking does
can you still dunk
um
I don't know I haven't tried you should
we every I could I could with it I could
last summer at the end of every set you
should wheel out a [__] rim and just
dunk and walk up I have I have a sh a
show idea I am dunked over you know like
like like how uh like who who like
um
like Chappelle Lacey will do a backflip
sometimes yes he does yeah but for me to
do that like I'm such a prop comic that
I need to bring out a hoop listen I told
Chappelle the same thing sooner or later
you're not gonna be able to do that
backflip so you gotta have something
else what happens when he finds out he
can't do it it's Gonna Hurt that's gonna
[__] yeah do you do it and then no I
can't do it or do you like if you miss a
dunk you get room checked right but what
happens if you miss that you [__]
fall on your neck probably scary yeah
yeah
um
first of all thank you for coming on
here and doing this this has been a
great episode I've learned quite a bit
about you thank you for having me we're
gonna have you on whenever it works for
you I would love it
um but now I want to ask you advice you
would give to 16 year old Rick Glassman
because that's an interesting time I it
and it ends up being an interesting time
for a lot of people but man you're going
through some [__] at that school and
everything so or you're just getting out
you're hybriding it maybe at that point
what are you hybriding yeah like you
said half day at this school had like a
hybrid I don't made up hybriding I get
it uh what would you what advice would
you give to 16 year old Rick other than
uh pick up a whole bunch of beta Alpha
unlimited and Arabian Nights magic cards
and just sit on them for a while because
that is number one is that oh my God
what are they worth dude are they like
baseball well baseball cards there's
nothing there's nothing like there's
magic cards
I mean
during the height of the pen during or
early 2020 when Collectibles really were
booming they've corrected since they're
still they're still not back to where
they were before then they're still up
um uh
I mean uh an alpha an alpha graded very
high Lotus is selling for I think it's
sold for like nine hundred thousand
dollars get the [__] out of here a card
oh yeah nine hundred thousand there was
there was two thousand I've ever made
um there's a uh I mean even now I bought
I bought um a uh every year I booked a
television show
I would get myself a gift
um
uh first season of Undateable I bought
myself a prostitute to lose my virginity
I was 14. right yeah um yeah I bought
myself a collectible uh and I have since
sold a fair amount of them um but
one of them was uh I bought a a beta
starter deck which came out in 93 it
says that on their 795 or 8.95 I bought
it I think for four grand and that's
easily selling not just worth selling
for near 30 now and that was just that
was you know six seven years ago
um uh when I first moved out here
um my Grandma had passed away and left
me ten thousand dollars and
I'm moving to California it helped me
with the confidence of it I found a
place and I have a couple thousand that
I'm using to pay for rent as I'm not
working and could a paycheck to paycheck
pay my rent I spent most of that money I
bought I bought um magic cards and uh
about uh four black lotuses at the time
between 800 and 1100 I sold them within
a year later I flipped them for up to
almost two grand so I made a little bit
of money wow um because I bought some
good quality ones and I got them graded
um not exaggerating now one of them I
bought an unlimited Black Lotus that I
ended up getting graded PSA 10 that sold
for last year I think uh 75 70 more at
least 75 000.
um dollars yeah uh I bought a a black
lotus that was said to be beta it ended
up being Alpha I was upset we don't need
to get into it why at the time Alpha was
you didn't want but I bought it for 800
I sold it for 12 to 14. that that is I
mean that's got to be in that not great
condition it's got to be 60 70 grand God
I mean damn some of these things if you
could find a sealed box of of these the
cards they're they're hundreds and
thousands of dollars it's
and so I would look at this sometimes
I'd look at this pack I keep it in a
safety deposit box and every now and
then I go like I'm visiting my kids and
I'll go and I'll take it out for a day
and I'll just and I go and I just look
at them like imagine having a whole
bunch of these so that's something I
would do
the other thing I would say is I guess I
mean this is very very corny but I'm so
grateful for all of all of that I am and
have and went through because uh I'm I
love
what who I am I love good so I am so
much I also didn't look at it as as like
everybody has their obstacles and their
traumas and I blindly accidentally
thought everything was great I always
thought I was the I am phenomenal thing
is like I am phenomenal and then I find
out wait am I not and I'm not phenomenal
and I'm back down I'm good I I didn't
know you know um I guess if I had to
give myself advice about things for when
I was feeling unincluded and or down
um I wouldn't be able to listen to it I
wouldn't I wouldn't because it's it's
too you you can't it's this is great
this is you know this is what it's
supposed to be
um I have some
advice that I gave myself as an adult
that I could have given to myself as a
kid but I don't think I could have
comprehended it and it came from stand
up
which was
um and I've also said this on my podcast
but I remember going up I would always
be very scared to go up but sometimes I
I've thrown up before going up I'm
shaking I'm very very nervous including
eight plus years in I just what am I
doing I don't do this what am I supposed
to talk about
um and there was a time I was at the
Hollywood improv and I was going up in
the main room and I remember being I'm
up next and you know that's when you're
gonna be nervous it's when you're about
to be up more so than when you're on and
I'm so nervous and I'm shaking my hands
are sweating and I made the decision to
like not hide it because if I hide it
then I'm just I'm not going to be
present I'm going to be like pretending
um and other people could go up and say
I'm nervous or whatever to acknowledge
and it's a great skill but more than
that more than the tool of
acknowledgment it there was this
acceptance of like I've been doing this
for almost 10 years I'm nervous I'm
supposed to be I'm gonna be it's just a
scary thing and this idea like I'm
supposed to be nervous as opposed to try
and hide it there's this confidence in
like I'm I'm a nervous guy why is
nervous a problem you are you should be
nervous before you go up yeah I just I
just had a conversation about this I saw
this interview at Mick Jagger where he
said he still gets nervous before he
goes out there and he's like if you
don't you're not alive it's not like
it's not real it's not normal to go do
what we do and you should be no like I'm
with you I when it used to when I first
started doing stand-up I'd be nervous
the whole day I had a gig I don't eat
much no you can't plan anything and
eventually that got to a few hours
before they arrived to the show then
when I'm at the venue now if you're up
ahead of me and you're like that's my
time or whatever that's when I really
start like yeah you know butterflies and
the adrenaline and then I walk out and
it's gone and the other thing about that
too is I I don't know why whenever good
or bad however my set's gone when I've
walked out there I haven't had the
butterflies disappear and it's one of
those things that I've never even
bothered to try to figure out why
because I don't want to [__] with it
it's been 20 years of when I'm out there
the butterflies are gone I can tell you
and it won't bother you it's great it's
the butterfly it's it's what we were
talking about with expectations the
nervousness isn't about
um how I'm doing
yeah it's the anticipation it's it's now
what and that's what the what those are
so beneficial and I call it a superpower
of being able to tap into being present
because it it because when you're
present nervous you're not worried about
what's happening this is just a chemical
feeling
you're just what is it going to be like
and when you're up there and you say the
wrong thing and you don't get a laugh
who gives a [__] really it doesn't you
just you might think uh but it doesn't
it's not it's not what what's gonna
happen it just did and nothing happened
um but the idea of of you're supposed to
be nervous and Mick Jagger being nervous
beforehand and you're getting these
butterflies at a certain point when you
recognize it's what it's supposed to be
it becomes a thing to where it's just
like
yeah when you're hungry you're hungry
it's just it's just a feeling
um and to appreciate that like the
things that we go through we're supposed
to on a spiritual level maybe there's
some things that like you know
I don't want it's we're at the end of
the podcast we don't get too much into
it but just basically the idea of like
I've developed a skill that I'm so
grateful for in comedy and and and just
socialize like play that I would not
have had if if things didn't go the way
it did
um
you know I've seen in movies where they
talk to like the nerdy kid and they're
like don't worry one day he's gonna be
working at a gas station which there's
nothing wrong with the movies and you're
going to be the president of the United
States you know like this idea of like
what will be
and that could maybe make people feel
good to think what will be but like
I I look back at like I look back at me
as a kid I just think he was so such an
I was so he was so nice and cute and
annoying and like tried so hard to be
friends and [__] up
um
yeah and that's all you're you're
supposed to be that I don't think I have
a close friend outside of the few that I
still am friends with it came from
basketball
most of them are now comedians I have a
close friend that didn't grow up feeling
unincluded not good enough weird ugly
when I and this this you meet a good
looking guy I'm talking like a hot guy
and he's funny
60 of the time at least he was a fat kid
you know like growing up feeling a
certain way lets you become something
so uh I wouldn't tell him to change
anything I guess it would just be like
great advice Maybe here's what I would
say when your OCD is flaring just keep
the socks on I used to it would take me
what is that it would take me five plus
minutes to get my socks on why
my OCD was was was I guess maybe figured
I don't know I don't know uh what I
would advise him you had to go through
it but I remember once I woke up I have
an anecdotes two minutes and it doesn't
matter should I tell her
uh I was always late for school because
I always had stomach aches my my parents
were driving to school I mean almost
every day
and uh one day I woke up a little early
and I'm like all right I'm gonna make my
mom like I want to be good and I'm gonna
get to get to school in time and
and I woke up before my mom because my
mom would always come in and wake me up
and I woke up before and I uh got my
socks on I don't remember five ten
minutes it took me to get my socks on
and I heard my mom coming and got under
the covers and my mom could get ready
for school and I woke up and I said I'm
dressed she said good and I remember I
and I got out and still in my pajamas
but my socks on and my mom never knew
that it took me so long to get my socks
on so she's like you're not dressed she
wasn't mad but I'm like I got my socks
on I remember them being like doesn't it
take you five minutes ten minutes to get
your socks on that's just one example
but like
yeah I mean brushing my teeth I would
have to hit the right numbers I would if
it would take me so long
um
so I guess it would be like hey Rick
just put the socks on man
you know what it's a good name for the
special just put this put the socks on I
like it
all right well I talked a lot this one I
appreciate your patience I saw you
holding me on a few times didn't need to
acknowledge it because cam will be on me
one time there's a couple of these I'm
not putting it on me or you but there
were a couple of these watch watch
you know that you ever see someone do
this
look at my eyes
[Laughter]
the eyes water after the dead giveaway
just
can you go like this
thank you dude yeah man uh promote
everything again please your podcast we
got the rode PSA One mic arm go to
Amazon look that up it's about 100 bucks
and it's [__] fantastic we have them
in the drawer
we literally have them but why not
because I like this better that had that
I do what may I make a suggestion sure
put one here have a third mic
and just if the guest wants it they can
pull it over yeah and you know what you
could do you could start every podcast
with pick your mic
I bet you I bet you probably not gonna a
lot of people why not because we did
that the start people didn't want this
they were just loud people would hit it
bang it all that [__] you know listen
you're asking a lot to trust people to
know how to use equipment you know I've
done about 200 episodes uh most of them
without mic arm you know the the main
complaint I get when people have that is
whoa too bad other people don't use this
and they're going like this
is like a real professional thing
I actually want to make a montage that I
could say I'm not gonna send you to put
on how many people like whoa you got you
got a real operation going on here
all right we'll look into it let's see
we got him in the drawer well I don't
know when this concept comes out when
you come back but I got a few in the can
so I'm I'm chilling out and recording
but once I'm doing the new setup uh I
want to have you on I can't wait I can't
wait to pull on that arm too you're
gonna like it might that might change I
think it might all right all right
um as always Ryan sickler.com Ryan
sickler on all social media we will talk
to you all next oh wait I didn't
actually take your shoes off podcast
check out yeah Rick lastman on Instagram
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign